(upbeat music)
(claps)
I can walk!
(laughs loudly)
Thanks a lot Andy, appreciate it.
Oh, I wasn't clapping for you
it just echoes in this empty room,
I like that sound.
Anyway what happened was
I'm backstage at the Largo Theater
that's where we're shooting
the show these days,
and there's all this stuff back there
and I found that cane
and I just thought I gotta use this cane.
So I came out and recreated
that magical moment
a little bit from Willy Wonka,
a little bit from sort of like
a Christian revival meeting.
Yeah yeah, it was good
it was good, I felt your faith.
Oh, I guess I can take this off.
Yeah.
Why are you, Andy you've
been wearing a face mask
around me since 1994?
Well,
I didn't want you to see me doing this.
(laughs)
Andy is, just for you so you know
Andy, all the time I've known him
now 27 years has been making
sort of erotic gestures
with his tongue constantly while talking
and the face mask has actually
been a nice break from that.
(laughs)
Yup
Yeah, okay that's not.
No, no.
Okay, all right, all right
let's take it easy there, pal.
Anyway, Andy as I say
you're welcome anytime to
move a lot closer if you want.
Yeah I'm lit here, it's
nice, it's comfortable.
You might like to be
a little closer to me.
Also I'm farting.
You're a good man, maybe
the best man I've ever known
but I don't get out a lot.
Now, welcome to our show
terrific show today,
one of our favorite people Patton Oswalt
on the show tonight.
(claps)
Yeah nothing's more demeaning to a comic
than the sound of one hand clapping.
(laughs)
[Andy] Good one.